i'm sure you've heard this saying many
times
to lose weight you got to eat less well
that's not entirely true losing weight
is not just about eating less
you don't have to drastically cut down
your food portion
and start eating like a rabbit you can
still enjoy a healthy normal serving
and still lose weight so this video is
in partnership with
circa dna which is currently the world's
most comprehensive dna tests this one
test can provide you with over
500 reports from diet and nutrition to
fitness
well-being stress and sleep skin
brain health ancestry and even cancer
risks
by knowing your own genetics you will
start to understand
your body better and you will be able to
make precise
and informed decisions about your health
in the future
you'll know exactly what to eat for your
body type the nutrients you might be
lacking
food you are sensitive or intolerant
towards and also
what kind of training suits you better
so why guess if you can have all the
information
through this one test this test is also
super convenient and simple
upon purchase you'll be sent this circle
dna kit
where you'll be able to do the swap test
at home and
send it back to them once your dna has
been analyzed
your results will be delivered through
their mobile app which
you can access anytime so all you need
is one test for a lifetime because your
genetics will not
change check out circuit dna in the link
below
so use the coupon code joanna at
checkout to get
one kit for 35 off two to three kids for
40
off and four or more kids for 50 off
this is applicable to any circus dna kit
you purchase
and this offer is limited to the first
100 kids
sold so do share this information with
your family and friends
once you know which diet type suits your
body
let's now apply these five tips to help
you
lose weight without eating less
not all calories are created equal
therefore the quality of food you eat
will be processed
differently in your body and this will
also influence your weight
real foods are high in nutritional value
and help you maintain a healthy weight
long term
on the other hand eating processed foods
can interfere with our body's
natural way of breaking down and storing
food
so what is real food it basically means
eating food
closest to its natural state and
minimally processed
real foods also tends to be perishable
and seasonal
simply put if you want to eat chicken
then
go for chicken not chicken nuggets
if you want to have potatoes then have
potatoes
not french fries when you consume real
food you will feel satisfied for less
you won't overeat and real foods are
much lower in calories
compared to processed food let's look at
the examples again
100 grams of chicken breast has 160
calories
versus chicken nuggets at 300 calories
100 grams of potato has 77 calories
versus french fries at 312
calories so as you can see it is not
just about eating less
it is about the quality of your food
just by making
this simple change towards eating real
food and
by processed food you will already start
to see and feel the difference
in your body
high volume foods are foods high in
water one example of high volume foods
include leafy greens you can literally
eat as much
leafy greens as you want and never gain
weight
for instance one cup of spinach only has
7
calories and it is packed with nutrients
other examples
include lettuce romaine watercress kale
collard greens bok choy and sweet chard
other high volume vegetables
are asparagus broccoli beetroot
cabbage carrots celery cucumber
zucchini and bell pepper so the trick
here
is to fill half of your plate with high
volume vegetables
at each meal this way you will get to
fill up on
very little calories besides vegetables
you can also add high volume fruits into
your meals
examples include lemon lime orange
grapefruit tomato peach strawberry
blueberry watermelon and honeydew fruits
are good for you but remember not all
fruits are low in calories
therefore choose more high volume fruits
another example is broth broth is
the ultimate high volume food clear miso
beef chicken vegetable or seafood broths
are very filling for very little
calories
so one cup of homemade chicken broth
only has about 18 calories
i like to make clear soup noodles and
toss in lots of vegetables and also lean
protein
this makes a great low calorie meal
that's satisfying
however if you were to use packaged
broth be aware
of the sodium content so choose low
sodium or sodium free broth
and consume them in moderation
perhaps you're enjoying a healthy diet
but the weight
still isn't shifting well are you one of
those people who enjoy your fruit juices
soda drinks fancy coffee or even alcohol
liquid calories in just about any form
are sneaky hidden calories those drinks
are loaded with calories
and some might even contain more
calories than a proper meal
for example one serving of caramel
frappuccino has
400 calories one cup of bubble tea has
three to four hundred calories that's
more than a healthy portion
at just about 350 calories if you start
counting how much calories you consume
from fluids
you might be surprised that it can add
up to 4
to 600 calories in just a day so just by
reducing on
fancy drinks and drinking more water you
will actually start to see the weight
shift other sneaky hidden calories are
in your sauces and also your dressings
a bowl of salad is healthy and is very
low in calories
but once you start to top it up with
sauces and dressings
it can turn into a very high calorie
meal one tablespoon of ranch dressing
has
73 calories and eight grams of fat
one tablespoon of mayonnaise has 94
calories
and 10 grams of fat one tablespoon of
sesame dressing has
62 calories and 6 grams of fat
so imagine if you were to add 2 to 3
tablespoons of dressing
because hey it's delicious that's an
additional of about
250 calories that you might not have
accounted for
which does not even fill you up so just
by being aware of the amount of dressing
you use
and swapping it with healthier
alternatives which are lower in calories
you will also reduce your total daily
calorie intake
which will contribute to weight loss
the fourth tip is something we often
overlook which is to practice
mindful eating basically stop stuffing
food into your mouth with our fast-paced
lifestyle nowadays most of us are guilty
of that including me
we tend to eat so fast without even
tasting our food
we eat with distractions and sometimes
we even eat food
that we don't even remember eating
that's worse because
it will just prevent you from achieving
your goals
when you focus on your food you get more
pleasure and satisfaction and as a
result you will start to feel satisfied
with less
and also lose weight so try these simple
tricks
to develop mindful eating put your food
on the plate avoid eating out of a bag
or straight from the refrigerator
or while you're standing up enjoy with
all your senses look smell your food
take small and slow bites to fully
appreciate the taste and texture
sit at a dinner table or a place that's
meant for a proper meal
instead of sitting on a couch avoid
distractions
so no eating in front of the tv computer
or doing any other activity besides
fully enjoying your meal
whenever possible choose places with dim
lights
because it has been shown to slow down
our eating pace
hence eating less bright fluorescent
lights in cafeteria of fast food joints
are meant to speed up your eating and
you
unintentionally end up eating more
having slow music playing in the
background can also slow down our eating
taste
and finally the speed of the other
person you're eating with can also
affect
your pace and the amount you eat if you
find that
the other person you dine with is eating
way too fast
and you feel the need to catch up
perhaps tell them
and ask them to slow down apply
these tips and naturally you will start
to listen to your body
and stop when you feel satisfied not
when
you are stuffed
and i can't stress this enough
get enough rest for many of us who have
been lacking sleep
we've forgotten what being really truly
rested
feels like lack of sleep has been linked
to being overweight
sleep is something we don't prioritize
in our busy and hectic lifestyle
but its impact is long term not getting
enough rest can disrupt your hormones
change the way you process sugar and
decrease the number of calories
you burn sleep affects the levels of two
hormones
leptin and ghrelin which controls the
feelings of fullness
and hunger latin sends a signal to your
brain that you have had
enough to eat without enough sleep your
brain reduces leptin
and increases ghrelin which is an
appetite stimulant
hence when you lack sleep you will also
notice that you
eat and crave for high sugar and high
fat
foods when you sleep less than 6
hours you're also putting your body
under stress
which increases cortisol levels in your
body
cortisol is a stress hormone that
enlarges
fat cells and promotes fat storage in
the belly so a combination of high
levels of ghrelin
and cortisol in your body is a disaster
so instead of slowly focusing on food to
lose weight
start to pay attention to your sleep by
getting at least
7 to 8 hours every night have a fixed
sleep schedule and avoid electronics at
least 30 minutes before bedtime
when we sleep well we wake up feeling
refreshed and alert to start our day
sleep is also one of the most important
aspects in losing weight and maintaining
a healthy weight for life
as we have learned losing weight is not
simply about eating less
by making a few small simple changes
that optimize your hormones reduce
hunger
and boost metabolism you can lose weight
without having to reduce
your food portion and the best part is
this is sustainable long term what other
methods have helped you to lose weight
without eating less let me know in the
comments below
if you enjoyed this video if you find
the tips to be useful then do share it
with your family and friends
give this video a thumbs up hit the
subscribe button if you haven't yet done
it
and also check out circle dna in the
description box below
and do also check out my youtube channel
for a lot more workout videos
fitness tips and also delicious healthy
recipes
and i will see you next time all the
best